today on the matt walsh show the
backlash against dave chappelle grows as
the media insists that any and all jokes
about or criticisms of
lgbt people are out of bounds and
automatically bigoted they say that lgbt
people are marginalized and that's why
you can't make these jokes but if you
aren't allowed to joke about a group of
people isn't that an indication that
they are the exact opposite of
marginalized also the high school
student who shot a teacher and two
classmates on wednesday was released on
bail on thursday less than 24 hours
later what's going on there and the new
york times claims that 900 000 children
have been hospitalized with covid which
is not even close to true and also a new
study confirms that women are attracted
to men who can provide for them
financially what does it say about our
society that we needed a study to
confirm that obvious fact we'll talk
about all of that and more today on the
matt wall show
[Music]
you know everybody has been talking
about abortion lately uh with what's
been happening in the news and down in
texas
and uh it's good that this conversation
is happening it's great with what's the
law down in texas but the problem is for
a lot of us uh we just don't know
exactly what to say how to engage with
these arguments uh and that's why if
you're struggling on what to say or how
to say when abortion is a topic
conversation you need to check out a
recent new book what to say when the
complete new guide to discussing
abortion it's already been a number one
amazon new release at a number two
amazon bestseller and it's on second
printing already so it tells you how
popular this book has been and for good
reason because it's a very easy book to
use it tells you what to say what not to
say and it's proven arguments that have
uh that have worked with everyone i mean
40 days for life they have even been
able to connect with and convert
abortion workers people at planned
parenthood 221 abortion workers have
seen the light thanks in large part to a
lot of these same arguments here so go
to the experts go to the people that um
know exactly what to say it's called
what to say when the complete new guide
to discussing abortion how to change
minds and convert hearts in a brave new
world go to amazon or get it directly
from 40 days for life at
40daysforlife.com
to begin with i must request well not
request but instruct demand that you
sign up for my newsletter if you haven't
already go to mattwallsreport.com
it's free so you are without excuse
don't make me ask again i am warning you
now on to the topic at hand the uh the
fallout continues from dave chappelle's
netflix comedy special where he uh
dared to crack one or two jokes at the
expense of the lgbt alphabet squad
most recently the showrunner for
netflix's anti-white series called dear
white people
says that he who identifies now as a she
will be boycotting the network by the
way this show runner who now goes by
jacqueline moore
is white so this is a white man who
identifies as a woman and makes an
anti-white show about black people
boycotting a black man for telling jokes
about trans people it's a it is a
tangled web of intersectionality there
here's what variety reports they say uh
quote jacqueline moore has always
considered dave chappelle one of her
comic heroes quote his shadow is huge
says moore who was a writer and
showrunner on netflix's dear white
people he's a brilliant goofy comedian
he's brilliant as a political comedian
he's been brilliant for so so long but i
also don't think
because you've been brilliant means that
you're always brilliant
after the chappelle special i can't do
this anymore i won't work for netflix
again as long as they keep promoting and
profiting from dangerous transphobic
content
uh she also tweeted
chic in quotes here i'm reading from the
variety that's what the word they're
using i love so many of the people i've
worked with at netflix brilliant people
and executives who have been
collaborative and fought for important
art but i've been thrown against walls
because i'm not a real woman i've had
beer bottles thrown at me so netflix i'm
done
we should note that moore apparently
according to variety transitioned into a
woman
during the pandemic so you know in the
last several months
and already he's incensed at the
suggestion that he's not a real woman
there have been many other reactions
along these lines glaad for example uh
released a statement saying
uh dave chappelle's brand has been
synonymous with ridiculing trans people
and other marginalized communities
negative reviews and viewers loudly
condemning his latest special is a
message to the industry that audience
audiences don't support platforming
anti-lgbtq diatribes we agree
and an lgbt group called the national
black justice coalition weighed in
saying
with 2021 on track to be the deadliest
year on record for transgender people in
the u.s the majority of whom are black
transgender people netflix should know
better perpetuating transphobia
perpetuates violence netflix should
immediately pull the closer from its
platform and directly apologize to the
transgender community
of course the claim that there's some
kind of epidemic of anti-trans murders
much less that these murders are
propelled by comedy specials
is uh pure fiction the vast majority of
trans murderers are drug or prostitution
related or they're due to domestic
violence
um but the lgbt lobby you know
reflexively lies about everything
so this is to be expected
the media has likewise been breathless
in its condemnations here's the headline
from npr says for dave chappelle punch
lines are dares
but his new special the closer goes too
far
and from the hill chappelle called out
for hostile transphobia and homophobia
in netflix special
and the guardian says dave chappelle
ricky gervais and comedy's ironic
bigotry problem
and the daily beast dave chappelle's
pointless transphobia and homophobia
and so on
now before we continue it probably makes
sense to actually listen to the segments
of the special that have provoked all of
this ire uh there are primarily two that
seem to have to have caused all this
trouble the first we played a few days
ago i'll play it again just to remind
you here is uh chappelle
pointing out that when it comes to
deciding what to be offended by we seem
to have our priorities a bit out of
whack
in our culture let's listen a lot of the
lgbtq community doesn't know the baby's
history he's a wild guy
he once shot
and killed him
in walmart
oh this is true google it the baby shot
and killed in walmart north carolina
nothing bad happened to his career
do you see where i'm going with this
in our country you can shoot and kill
but you better not hurt a gay person's
feelings
[Music]
i guess i should have clarified uh it's
a bit of setup there was probably
necessary that he's talking about a
rapper named the baby he's not referring
to an actual baby
who shot and killed someone at walmart
uh though i i you know i think i have
seen babies walking around with handguns
at walmart um but this is a rapper his
name is the baby and in fairness the
baby um who you know of course i'm a big
fan of of all of his work
um says he says that he shot the the guy
in self-defense
in in the walmart um
the guy was trying to rob him in the
middle of a walmart and shot yeah i
don't know i don't know if he did or
didn't
but i do know that the baby brags in his
music about murdering people all the
time i mean he like most rappers
glorifies
murder drug dealing violent crime and so
on
so even if he hadn't actually killed a
guy himself still it would seem
far more offensive to promote actual
murder
than to make insulting comments about
gays
so the point from chappelle stands no
matter the particulars of uh
that case there at walmart
but i think it's chappelle's comments
about gender and trans people that have
gotten most of the attention
and have caused most of the uh the
backlash of people calling for him to be
to be canceled and here they are here
you canceled jk rowling my god jk
rowling wrote all the harry potter books
by herself
she sold so many books the bible worries
about her
and it canceled her because she said in
an interview and this is not exactly
what she said but effectually she said
gender was a fact
and then the trans community got mad
they started calling her a turf
i didn't even know what that was
but i know that
trans people make up words to win
arguments
so i looked it up
turf is an acronym stands for
trans-exclusionary radical feminists
this is a real thing this is a group of
women
that hate transgender they don't hate
transgender women but they look at trans
women the way we blacks might look at
blackface it offends them like she's
doing an impression of me
look at it like this caitlyn jenner whom
i've met wonderful person caitlyn jenner
was voted
woman of the year
her first year as a woman ain't that
something beat everybody in detroit
she's better than all of you
gender is a fact this is a fact every
human being in this room every human
being on earth had to pass through the
legs of a woman to be on earth that
is
a fact
uh now
a couple of points in fact you notice
one thing that kind of stands out
uh
even in the context of making
the points that he makes here
he's still respecting the pronouns right
he still calls caitlyn jenner her in a
sheet
and that's what you find that that it's
it's so rare
even the people who are willing and it
takes guts to do it i give them credit
for it
so i'm not trying to take anything away
from her split hairs here but
it's not really splitting hairs
even the people who are willing to stand
up
and point out
some of the truth
and um cr you know and make some of
these criticisms
most of them are not willing to go all
the way very few people very few
are willing to go all the way on this
and totally reject
left-wing gender ideology completely
there are very few people willing to do
that
um a couple other points first you know
chappelle has made jokes about all
different groups and demographics
he jokes about white people all the time
he's a comedian that's what comedians
are supposed to do
most of the people offended by the two
clips i just played would not be
offended and have not been offended by
any of his jokes about literally any
other group of people
none of them
should the alphabet squad really be
exempt from all mockery should they be
the one single group that nobody ever
makes fun of
the answer according to his critics
is yes
that's that is their answer you can make
fun of anybody just not them and the
reason they give for that is that uh
they say that uh attacking lgbt people
or or not even attacking but making
jokes about them is uh punching down
it's punching down but the actual reason
is exactly the opposite of that
you know there's that old saying i don't
remember who who coined it originally
but that you can tell who has the power
in any society based on who you're not
allowed to criticize
and that's a rule that will rarely steer
you wrong and it certainly does not here
the reason you can criticize everybody
except lgbt people is that they hold the
cultural power
you get canceled for making jokes about
the alphabet squad simply because the
alphabet squad has the power to cancel
people
they they're the ones who can do it they
can they could chew they could choose to
tolerate such mockery or not and they
certainly choose not to because you're
not going to find much in the way of
self-deprecating humility among lgbt
leftists or among any any form of
leftist
um
when it comes to leftism narcissism is
part of the game and a narcissist is not
going to be happy with you making any
jokes about them at all
corporate america
the media
academia
the government
school system hollywood
all
bow in
service bow in submission to the lgbt
lobby
all are largely run by the lgbt lobby
we're told that lgbt people are
marginalized
but if you want to know what
marginalized actually means and what it
looks like
then look at lgbt
and imagine the precise opposite of that
they have way outsized influence and
power relative to their numbers
that's not what marginalized means
you know what marginalized this you know
you know who the marginalized people are
the people who listen to that last
segment from chappelle and agree with it
they're the marginalized ones
the people who know that biological sex
is a fact
the people who know that only women give
birth
and who would prefer to live in a
society that recognizes that fact
and a society that uh that
cherishes women and femininity
because it is unique and special
and not anyone can partake in it just
because they identify with it in their
heads
those are the people who are
marginalized
and how do you know they're marginalized
because they're in the majority
but their influence
is way
undersized
um
relative to their numbers
that's what it means to be marginalized
it means you're pushed to the peripheral
it means that you're ignored
okay when you're ignored and pushed to
the peripheral you're being marginalized
who could anyone with a straight face
well they can
apparently
uh but it's it's kind of mind-boggling
that they can with a straight face that
anyone with a stray face could claim
that lgbt people are marginalized
pushed to the peripheral
ignored
really
i mean they get their own month
and i think we're in the middle of
another month right now because right
now i believe is lgbt history month i
could be wrong so you know every month
in some ways a celebration
again the the opposite of marginalized
marginalized are the people
who agree with dave chappelle there
they're being marginalized
and that's exactly why even though what
chappelle is saying especially the very
end
that everybody who's on earth today or
has ever been born
had to pass through a woman in order to
be born
like i said yesterday
if someone had told you back in 2000
like 20 years ago
know if you could have looked into the
future if you were
flipping through the channels and
stumbled on
a channel that was broadcasting from 20
years in the future and you saw that
segment and someone told you that that
would be considered controversial 20
years from now
you would be filled with with you
wouldn't believe it and you but if you
did you'd be filled with dread and
terror right like are you so we you're
saying society completely loses its mind
well yeah
in the future
but the reason why it becomes kind of a
big deal
is because the vast majority of people
recognize that this is true
that biological sex is a fact
uses the word gender there really what
he means is biological sex gender is a
you know gender as it relates to people
is an invention
um
biological sex is a fact only women give
birth like this this is something that
everyone recognizes most people the vast
majority
and the reason why
you know they celebrate something like
dave chappelle
is because a lot of people even though
they recognize these basic truths
they've been they've been pushed to the
margins
and now they feel like they need
permission
they need someone who's in the
mainstream some prominent person
to say whatever what they all recognize
to be true
and it's sad that people are waiting for
permission to speak basic truths
but that's where we are and that's what
it means to be marginalized
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
maybe you've had this experience before
of uh you got a call or text or an email
from someone posing as an irs agent or a
police officer or the power company
demanding payment by a gift card well if
you have you're probably being targeted
for a gift card scam these fraudsters
trick victims into sending online gift
cards or reading the numbers from a gift
card over the phone
i mean it should be a pretty good if
someone in the irs is saying send me a
gift card or a cop is calling you up i
should be pretty good indication that
it's a scam but sometimes the scams are
not always obvious and that's why it's
so important to understand how cyber
crime and identity theft are affecting
our lives every day every day we put our
information at risk on the internet in
an instant a cyber criminal could harm
what's yours your finances your credit
everything well it's a good thing
there's light flock lifelock helps
detect a wide range of identity threats
and if they detect your information has
potentially been compromised they're
going to send you an alert and help you
get everything back to normal look
nobody can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses but you can keep what's yours
with lifelock by norton join now and
save 25 off your first year at
lifelock.com walsh that's lifelock.com
walsh for 25 off so this is pretty funny
uh
it's it's funny until it's used as a
basis for uh further censorship which it
will be but
apparently
twitter has rolled out a new warning so
they've got you know they've got the
misinformation warnings
which really the way the misinformation
warnings are applied it's oftentimes
like inconvenient information they call
misinformation
so if you're talking about covid and
you're not in line with the covet cult
they're gonna put a misinformation
warning they got different kinds of
warnings
that they'll put on your on your content
potentially here's a new one that they
just unveiled and i found out about it
because they put it on one of mine
and now they have on twitter
and i'm pretty sure this is not meant to
be a joke
they have intensity warnings
so if you're tweeting if you put out an
intense tweet
then they'll put a warning on it a heads
up letting everybody know that this is a
little bit intense
so yesterday i tweeted about um
like we discussed on the show yesterday
vaccinating kids and i said i'm not i'm
not going to vaccinate my kids
and i have very good science
scientifically based reasons for that
because covid is not and we'll get more
into this in a minute but covet is not a
serious threat to them that's why i'm
not getting vaccinated and someone
responded to me and said
there's well there's plenty of good
reasons to vax your kids even though
they aren't at risk
and i responded and said okay please
give me one good reason
pretty fair response
that person by the way never gave a good
reason instead they put their account on
private
i've said give me one good read i'm
really curious
if you're admitting
that kids are not at risk from covid
they're at effectively at no risk
the risk is so small that it's
you know effectively new
um
if
but if you admit that and then you still
say there's a good reason to get the
vaccine well what is it tell me what the
reason is
i'd love to hear it well this person
didn't respond but on that tweet
responding to that guy
twitter put up
a warning it says heads up
conversations like this can be intense
is anyone going to see a warning like
that and say oh
i don't want any of the intense stuff
i'm going to keep scrolling here
it is true i do have some intense tweets
there's no denying that all right so
this is from the post-millennial says
as the student who allegedly injured
four people in a school shooting at his
arlington texas high school he's been
released um and he was released on
thursday afternoon after posting 75
thousand dollars in bail
okay so this guy not a kid he's 18 years
old this man
shot uh
multiple people in a school on wednesday
and on thursday 24 hours later he's
walking out of there on only 75 000 bail
uh simpkins will be confined to his home
pending his trial under the conditions
of the bail agreement he'll also be
closely monitored by gps and will have
to undergo regular testing for alcohol
and other drugs
um he faces three counts of aggravated
assault with a deadly weapon
and um
two teachers were hurt in the incident
one was shot
he was shot in the back and has a
collapsed lung broken ribs
and then there were two other people who
who were injured from gunfire
now
so he's getting out on bail
after i mean this is a school shooting i
think if you shoot
people get shot into school that counts
as a school shooting
and he's walking out of there on 75 000
bail
a day later
um
now the family though they're insisting
that well this is different from your
your typical school school shooting it's
not the same kind of thing
this is from fox it says the family of
an 18 year old student suspected of
opening fire and injuring four people at
a texas high school and wednesday claims
that he was being bullied and brought
the handgun to protect himself
um
and the details of the of the fight what
they say is that uh arlington police
said cell phone video shows a fight
breaking out
before simpkins fired the gun
um the claim is that the video shows
simpkins was being attacked and there is
a video that i've seen floating around
online of
and
the claim is that this is the fight that
happened it's not really a fight there's
one guy being brutally assaulted while
someone else just whales on him it's not
really what you see in the video anyway
is not really a fight it's also not
clear who's doing the whaling on on who
uh based on that video so i'm not sure
about that
but what police are saying is that um
is that this
altercation this fight this assault
happened
and then
uh
the the teacher stepped in to break it
up
and it seemed like everything was calmed
down
and that's when allegedly simpkins went
into his backpack pulled the gun out and
started firing
and if that's what happened
then number one that's not self-defense
you know something happens in the moment
you're being assaulted and you shoot
somebody then that's self-defense but
the it's over and that person is is
being restrained
and the fight's over and then you pull
it out and shoot
that's that's revenge that's not that's
not self-defense
and a school shooting
because someone was bullied and they're
looking for revenge
uh that's
not all that unique that's very often
what you find with these school
shootings
fortunately nobody was killed in this
case it looks like uh you know everyone
who was injured is going to recover from
their injuries
and from what it sounds like he wasn't
he didn't just start randomly executing
his classmates thank god
but he brought the gun to school
and then he fired it apparently after
the fight was over
seemingly to get revenge
because he was angry
not not all that different from uh from
the the you know the what leads up to
many different school shootings
and yet he's walking out of there on 75
000 bail a day later
and we have to mention here that the
school shooter in this case
uh is a black guy
and the reason why we have to mention
that
is because it is
repeatedly insisted
that from blm and uh and the left
generally and the media
that white suspects get preferential
treatment how often have we heard i'm
sure you've heard this a million times
especially if you spend any time on
social media anytime there's a shooting
or
especially a police shooting what you
always hear is about um
dylan roof
you know the uh the church shooter
got
was arrested and then got burger king
and they claim he's of course a white
white man shooting uh black people and
so they claim oh this is this is what
they do for white shooters
he killed all these people and they and
they brought him to burger king
well they didn't bring him they didn't
like bring him to the they didn't
on on the way you know to jail they
didn't stop at burger king and sit down
with him
um no they brought him to the
interrogation room and uh and they they
brought him like a hamburger or
something they just went down the street
to get the cheapest hamburger they could
find they gave it to him because they
have to
you you have to you have to feed
suspects after you arrest them you can't
withhold food if you do that
you know it could interfere with the
whole case
it's going to interfere with your
ability
to convict this person
and get the sentence that he deserves
if his defense attorney can claim that
uh this is cruel unusual punishment
you're
you're refusing to feed him and all that
kind of stuff so they're legally
required they do this for everyone
you may be shocked to learn that in that
in every prison in america they provide
food everybody
convicted murderers and serial killers
they give them food they have to do that
uh and then dylann roof as he deserves
was convicted and sentenced to death
so i'm just i'm trying to imagine
if this was ex exact same circumstances
but this was a white
school shooter
let out on bail
24 hours after being arrested
on 75 000 bill what would we be hearing
right now from the media
i think we all know we'd be hearing
and it is kind of interesting because we
have this case along with in the exact
same week as we discussed yesterday
a gang shooting
in chicago where gang members are
shooting at each other in the middle of
the day someone is killed
and uh and and the d.a decides to press
no charges at all
they all just walk out scot-free
and yet there's some sort of
pro-white systemic bias in the in the
court system
well this is certainly not what you
would expect to see is it
based on the theory of pro-white
systemic bias in the court system
all right biden president biden gave a
speech about the importance of vaccine
mandates yesterday and at one point he
launched into a story and uh i don't
know i i just couldn't tell what he was
trying to get across here so maybe you
can tell me
jerry every company uh
needs people like you every single one
someone who knows uh
what my dad taught me and a lot of
people who know me well
including the governor's sister who i
worked closely with for eight years my
dad used to have an expression
he used to say everyone's entitled to be
treated with dignity and joey
a job's a hell of a lot more than about
a paycheck
it's about your dignity
it's about your place in the community
it's about being able to look your kid
in the eye and say honey everything's
going to be okay that's a god's truth he
said every time ever since he lost
things went south in scranton
pennsylvania when i was a kid and coal
shut down
my dad was not a coal miner i had a
great grandfather called minor engineer
but you know he was a salesperson
everything we moved down to wilmington
delaware a little town called claymont
tell a little steel town there's no
steel anymore but right on the border of
pennsylvania
and
it was always about the dignity of work
and what you've been doing here about
this pandemic is about protecting the
dignity the dignity of your fellow
americans you know
uh you stayed in an operations mode
lining up protective equipment for the
rest of the country
uh what
i'm not exactly sure what he was
trying to say there as he as he
took us along this windy windy path of
whatever that story was supposed to be
i did pick up on the part about the
dignity of work and you know everybody
should have a job and there's dignity in
that
and he tells that story
if we can recall it a story
uh that that mishmash of sentences all
jumbled together he tells that while
selling this idea of vaccine mandates at
on the job
so everyone you know has a right to a
job and there's
the dignity of work meanwhile if you
don't inject this substance into your
body whether you need it or not
maybe you have natural immunity but even
if you whether you need it enough you
don't if you don't inject this substance
into your body we're going to take that
job away from you
that's a policy a mandate you come up
with because you respect the dignity of
work where's the dignity in that
forcing a drug into people's bodies as a
condition of employment
that's dignity
it's not just dignity he says it's also
economic stimulus
but here's what wall street's saying
goldman sachs quote vaccinations will
have a positive impact on employment it
means less spread of covet 19 which will
help people return to work
moody's in wall street
vaccination means fewer infections
hospitalizations than death in turn it
means a stronger economy
one economist called vaccine
requirements and i quote the single most
powerful i didn't say single the most
powerful economic stimulus ever enacted
and the quote
third point i'd like to make the report
shows that vaccination requirements have
broad public support
well that economist if he exists is a
[ __ ]
so firing people from their jobs is
economic stimulus
it's also the way that we protect the
dignity of work
that's actually the dignity of work and
human human dignity generally
that's one of my primary arguments
against the vaccine mandate as a
condition of employment
yeah there's a matter of basic freedom
and liberty here
but to me even more importantly it's
dignity
you're not treating human beings with
dignity
when you tell someone we're going to
take away your ability to feed your
family unless you comply with us and put
this substance into your body again
whether you need it or not
speaking of people who don't need it
this is from uh the blaze and about uh
the new york times
doing a little bit of fear-mongering and
then having to issue one of their um
standard traditional retractions it says
new york times issued a lengthy
correction
after numerous mistakes an article about
coronavirus vaccinations for children
including the egregious exaggeration of
chronovirus hospitalizations among u.s
children
uh the article by
mendevilli documented how the u.s is
forging ahead on full vaccination for
children while other countries are
experimenting with just one shot after
weighing the risks
um
but in documenting the extent of the
chronovirus pandemic among children in
the u.s
mandavilli missed the mark by a wide
margin
the times issued a correction noting
several issues with the article this is
their correction part of it anyway it
says the article misstated the number of
covet hospitalizations and u.s children
it is more than 63 000 from august 2020
to october 2021 not 900 000 since the
beginning of the pandemic
and then they also were wrong about
uh vaccination policies in sweden and
denmark
they were wrong i mean they they got
five or six details wrong in this
article which means you shouldn't be
issuing a
a correction this should be just be a
full retraction
because the the basis for this article
article is wrong
everything is wrong you should be
retracting it but instead they
they just issue the correction you're
never going to convince me that this
isn't intentional
i mean there's there's no way you could
be how where did 900
900 000 hospitalizations
of of children from covid
and the real number is 63 000.
it's not even as though they added an
additional zero by accident like a typo
where did you get that number
it it
one second on google will tell you the
truth there
and i'm supposed to believe that's an
accident it's not
they get the falsehood out there it
implants in people's minds and then they
know the correction is never as widely
seen as the original claim they know
that
so there's lots of people now who have
that 900 000 figure in their head
when the real number is a fraction of
that
and this article is all supposed to be
you know it does it admits
that in most other countries around the
world
you know they are not nearly as eager
to start putting kids on full
vaccination schedules
they're also not masking kids to this to
nearly the same extent that we are
okay we are one of the only countries in
the world that has decided to act as
though children are just as susceptible
to the virus as everybody else
most other countries are not doing that
we are among the only ones to do it
even countries that broadly speaking
their lockdowns and their coveted
policies have been stricter than ours
still most of them recognize that
children just are not susceptible
you could put it this way
there is no pandemic for kids
okay for kids as far as our kids are
concerned there is no pandemic
that's how small the risk is to them
in fact if you look at it
you look at all the deaths
all the
deaths among children
over the last year you know year or two
years
what you'll find is that less than one
percent less than one percent of all
child deaths during that period are
attributed to covet less than one
percent
less than point zero zero zero six
percent point zero zero zero six percent
of the child population as a whole in
this country has died of covet over the
last two years
that's not a pandemic that's not that's
not an epidemic that's that's just not
a great many
risks
um
are you know are
more fatal to kids than covetous
and we've just decided to
ignore that fact
what i've been told that someone just
told me this on twitter
a couple hours ago
when trying to justify the fact that
we're you know coming up with policies
pretending that kids are acceptable as
everybody else and what i've been you
know we've heard this many times but
uh once again i was told that um
that uh you know one child is too many
and uh what if my child yeah yeah it's
only point zero zero zero six percent
but uh what if my child was in that
point zero zero six percent
how would i feel about it then well yeah
if if my if one of my children had been
one of the very very very few
to die of covet
then yeah i'd probably be singing a very
different tune
just like if if i had a child who god
forbid
drowned in a pool
i'd probably say we should ban all pools
if i had a child who choked to death on
a chicken nugget i'd be saying let's ban
all chicken nuggets
you know i would certainly wish that i
could go back in time
and erase you know if it were up to me
pass these sweeping laws you know to
keep my child alive of course i'd want
to do that
you know personally as a parent there's
probably no tyranny
that i that i wouldn't visit upon you
and the world
in order to save my children's lives
there's probably nothing that i wouldn't
do to save my own children's lives
and i admit that
but when it comes to making public
policy
you cannot make public policy
with
from
while assuming the mentality of a
desperately grieving parent
because
emotionally for me to feel this way
about my own kids is entirely
justifiable and understandable
but it is not a basis for public policy
obviously
yeah if i if i whoever anyone listening
right now
if i knew that locking you specifically
in your home for the rest of your life
is what i needed to do
for some reason
to keep one of my kids alive i would do
it i would take away all your liberty to
keep my kid alive
i recognize that emotionally
but does that mean that we should mix
policy that way
no
all right here's uh terry mcauliffe in
my former home state of virginia
now terry mcauliffe has said that uh the
critical race theory is not being taught
in schools
uh so all this stuff in this
the school board meetings and everything
this is all it's actually racist he says
this um
campaign against critical race theory is
racist in and of itself because critical
race there isn't being taught at all
this is all a dog whistle but then he's
asked uh in this interview with local
media if he can even tell us what
critical race theory is and he can
listen
so how do you define it anita it is not
taught here in virginia how do you
define it it doesn't matter it's not
taught here in virginia so i'm not going
to speak
on what it is i'm not even spending my
time because the school board and
everyone else has come out and said it's
not talk it's racist
it's a dog whistle but if we don't have
a definition how can we say it's racist
i just want a definition from you
it's not taught here in virginia we can
ask about any topic here's what i've
said all along and it really bothers me
you know i re it really bothers me this
whole idea of stirring parents up to
create the divisions our children are
going through such challenges today
because of kovid and we're talking about
something here today wasting
precious viewers time
so he has of course
and you can always this is always a fun
thing to do when you're dealing with
democrats
or any leftist um
just the first thing you should do
whatever term they're using
get them to define it
what exactly are you talking about and
they'll always treat it as some sort of
trick question that you you you simply
they're using words and you want to know
what they mean by those words and
they're going to do well what do you
mean listen
what is this a gotcha there's a game of
gotcha no this is a game of i want to
understand what the hell you're saying
that's what the game is
so he has no idea what critical race
theory is and yet he doesn't know what
it is yet he's quite certain that um
it's not in the school system
when of course it is
when when kids are taught from a young
age in school as they are now
that uh america is systemically racist
you know that it was that it was uh that
it's racist at its very core
uh that all white people are
have privilege by nature of their race
that all white people are inherently
racist
that no black person or or person you
know non-white person can be racist
because race is based on uh power and
privilege
power press plus prejudice equals racism
when kids are taught that
all of that that is critical race theory
that is critical that's sort of it's a
distillation
uh a boiled down version of critical
waste
so glad i could help you out mcauliffe
one more thing here before we get to
reading the comments this is from cnn
sad news
apparently sad news supposedly says the
ivory-billed woodpecker along with 22
other species of birds fish mussels and
other wildlife is set to be declared
extinct and removed from the endangered
species list
according to u.s wildlife officials
it says the u.s fish wildlife service
said for the species proposed for
delisting today the productions of the
nature species act came too late with
most either extinct functionally extinct
or in steep decline at the time of
listing
also slated for delisting are the
bachmann's warbler two species of
freshwater fishes eight species of
southeastern freshwater mussels and
eleven species from hawaii and pacific
island uh sorry i'm scrolling through
this thing eagerly
trying to see if they list pandas on
this and they don't no the pandas are
still lingering along well yeah i don't
know what we're gonna do
without the the bachmann's warbler
that's okay
isn't that that's a great tragedy the
bachmann's warbler isn't going to be
joining us on earth anymore
i'm i'm sorry i who can't
who cares
why does it who cares that these species
are going extinct what do we need them
for
this this one version of a woodpecker
isn't going to be around anymore oh okay
well there's other woodpeckers around
that can fill their place i'm sure they
can they can pick up the woodpecker
baton they can't really pick it up
because you know but metaphorically
speaking
i just don't understand and if we're
told that climate change is gonna is
gonna kill us all
then why are we trying to keep other
species around that are emitting you
know with their carbon emissions
it adds up
so should we should we be celebrating
this kind of thinning the herd a little
bit i don't know but for climate change
and environmentalists they want to thin
the herd among people not among the
bachmann's warbler or the uh or the
ivory-headed
woodpecker
that's what they want to do
so when they hear for these there's how
twisted these people i know when i say i
don't care if these species are going
extinct
you know people hear that and they're
horrified by it sounds like i'm some
sort of sociopath
and maybe i am
but consider the fact that for a lot of
other people
if when they hear about human
populations declining they're happy
about that
they're more upset about the decline of
the bachmann's warbler than they are
about people
uh declining in population numbers
so if you could do that with if you
could say as so many people do
about their own species ah what do we
need so many of us for
you could say that about your own
species i can't say it about a
about a species of muscle or
some kind of clam or what whatever you
know
horned owl in the forest
i'm sorry i just don't i don't i don't
care
that's fine they can go extinct
here listen
millions
of animal species
uh went extinct
before human civilization ever existed
okay we've had human civilization for i
don't know
10 000 years let's say
millions
billions of of animal species went
extinct before that ever happened
before we were even building you know
before before pyramids were had even
been built
millions of animal species went extinct
was that some kind of great tragedy
now now it's like
species extinction is part of the cycle
of life
and now every single species that goes
extinct it's our fault
if we weren't around many of these
species would still be going extinct and
yet some kind of it's now that we're
here it's a tragedy and we've got to
keep them we have to hold all of these
do our best to hold all of these
different warblers and woodpeckers into
existence hold them in the palm of our
hand oh no we can't lose any of them why
all right i'm getting probably more
passionate about this than i need to
uh i just i have a thing you know i
don't like pandas and i don't like the
bachmann's warbler either good riddance
let's get uh now to read in the
polka comments and flannel shirts
without shame
do you know their name
they're the sweet baby gang
crystal says matt isn't the fact that
the dog was wary towards an unfamiliar
man a good thing since you wanted it as
protection for your family that was your
only reasoning for wanting a dog at all
right
uh
yeah i'm glad that he's that he's
protective but my issue is i'm not going
to tolerate
disrespect in my own home
okay and the dog doesn't get off the
hook
hold everyone to the same standard
uh
let's see lou says
is walsh going to rent places throughout
the u.s so he can attend local school
board meetings walsh could critic would
criticize
some hollywood celebrity if they crashed
a local school board meeting where they
don't live but it's fine if he does it
local people are perfectly capable of
speaking for themselves they don't need
walsh riding in as their spokesman
but of course walsh knows that this is
good publicity for himself in his bottom
line
now walsh is hawking some quack
treatment for puffy eyes he's a real man
of principle listen lou
you can slander me all you want
but i will not have you saying these
things
about genusel by chaminix
which can solve under ag eye
under eye
puffiness in a matter of days
how dare you sir
david says
matt what is your favorite bible
translation did i answer did i already
answer this one i'm having i'm having a
deja vu well anyway
favorite bible translation uh i'm not
i'm not especially loyal to
one particular translation or another
uh and if you don't if if you don't know
hebrew or greek
um which are the the language the
languages that the the old and new
testament respectively were written in
if you don't know those language like if
you know those languages
and you can read
the scriptures in their original
languages
then do that i mean that's the best
thing you can do
but if you don't
then unfortunately you are relegated to
and this is the case for any kind of
translation even if it's not the bible i
mean you could be reading russian
literature or something
um if if you don't know the original
languages you're left with somewhat of a
pale imitation of of of
what there really is and there's always
this kind of balance that translators
have to strike between
uh do i do we literally translate the
words
or do we try to capture the overall
meaning because that's not always the
same thing that's the way language works
and so with any translation again bible
or any kind of book
they're going to be some translations
that are more literal some that are more
focused on meaning and then some that
are just terrible and um
so with with you know so i i kind of it
depends on what
book of the bible i'm reading
you know that might determine which
translation i prefer
the flowery language of the kjv king
james version
is um
it certainly does not really capture the
act especially for the gospels in the
new testament i mean the gospels
the the epistles
this is these were written in plain
language
for ordinary people they weren't written
in the you know in the equivalent of
shakespearean
eloquent prose right
um
so i don't really like that for for the
new testament but i'll you know for old
testament i kind of think it works so
that's my answer which isn't really an
answer at all i'm equivocating
and finally robert says matt i believe
duels were more of a daybreak kind of
thing high noon seems like a sheriff
outlaw deal at any rate this culture is
screwed
uh yeah well daybreak is way too early
for a duel i need a little bit of time i
need to have some coffee if i'm going to
be participating and the thing is i'm
actually not i think i've advocated
before
for legalizing dueling i think there's
there's an argument you could be that
could be made for that
um but if you're going to do it then
then you have to really do it and what
they've done in chicago
is they've kind of just done it in
effect they've in effect decriminalized
dueling and if you're also going to have
a dual there have to be rules that you
respect
right you've got it's not gonna be five
five on five just spraying bullets all
over the place
you know there's a certain you're going
certain number of paces apart
it's time to you figure out what the
rules are
and you settle your differences that way
i think you could make an argument that
a society that has legalized dueling is
going to be a much more polite society
it's gonna be a society where you put
your shopping carts back if you know
that i could challenge you to a duel if
you don't
uh but what they've done in chicago is
stiff it's it's not really legalized
dueling it's just legalized utter total
chaos
where gangs can shoot each other
willy-nilly in the street
hitting innocent bystanders in the
process potentially and uh they're not
gonna be charged with any crime this
coming tuesday october 12th we're taking
backstage to an entirely new level
instead of the usual daily wire studio
we'll be live streaming our conversation
on stage at the famous ryman auditorium
right here in nashville doing what we do
best making sense this will be an event
and a live stream unlike any we've done
before and we're thrilled to be able to
share it with all of you plus we'll be
making some extremely exciting
announcements um which you will not want
to miss so be sure to tune in join
myself ben shapiro candice owens jeremy
boring michael knowles andrew clavin and
our live audience for a backstage like
never before tuesday's live stream will
begin at 8 30 pm eastern 7 30 pm central
so head to dailywire.com or
dailywireyoutube to catch the show and
also this is a reminder it's everyone
listening that as the daily wire
continues to grow we're seeking talented
candidates for open positions across
several departments within the company
our current list of open positions on
the team here at daily wire includes but
is not limited to
video editor writer and reporter
publicity manager sales representative
social media content creator
uh podcast marketing manager
conversion rate optimization specialist
and 2pm podcast host
well that's not a good sign
if you think you've got what it takes to
join one of the fastest growing
conservative media companies in america
we want to hear from you for a full list
of job openings and open positions and
position details and to apply please
visit
dailywire.com
careers now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
you know we've been conditioned not to
trust our own common sense anymore which
is why we so often need studies to
confirm the obvious but most of us
don't trust studies either and for good
reason in in most cases so that's not
much help but here's here's one study
that i think we can take to the bank so
to speak there's a pun there which will
make more sense as we proceed
reading now from an article on the
institute for family studies website
written by rosemary l hopcroft which
sounds like a character in an agatha
christie novel and i don't mean that as
a as an insult um she writes quote in
21st century america over half of all
married couples are dual earner families
and men are no longer expected to be the
sole source of financial support for
their families it seems therefore that
possession of means would no longer
matter as much for men's marriage
prospects while at the same time it may
matter more for women's marriage
prospects yet my new research published
in the journal evolution and human
behavior shows that possession of means
still matters when it comes to marriage
and family formation for men but not for
women in other words men are going to
have an easier time getting married if
they have money but for women it doesn't
matter much one way or another
continuing it says for men as income
increases the probability of marriage
also increases such that men in the
highest income category are about 57
percentage points more likely to marry
than men in the lowest income category
the same is not true for women
high-income men are more likely than
low-income men to marry while income is
unrelated to marriage for women given
that marriage involves choice on both
the man and the woman's part these
results suggest that women are more
likely to choose to marry men with good
financial prospects while a woman's
financial prospects are less important
to men when choosing a marriage partner
now every broke single guy listening to
this right now is certainly well aware
of this dynamic
all too familiar with it but again these
days we need this kind of research to
tell us what we already know
though many of us have chosen to pretend
we don't know it
a little more from the article says not
only are high income men more likely to
marry they're more likely to stay
married too figure two talking about the
chart
shows the probability of divorce for
those who have been married at least
once and reveals that for men the
probability of divorce declines as
income rises such that men in the
highest income category are about 37
percentage points less likely to divorce
than men in the lowest income category
for women the probability of divorce
increases as income rises perhaps mostly
due to reverse causality and the fact
that divorce uh divorced women are more
likely to have to support themselves
financially for men the results suggest
that women are more likely to divorce
low-income men
than high-income men
now
the cynical interpretation of all this
is that women are materialistic and
superficial
and some women are just like some men
are but
that doesn't explain
these trends generally speaking as the
study demonstrates and thousands of
years of human experience confirms
women are looking for stability they're
looking for a provider
they value ambition
they value work ethic in a man
and that's anything but superficial to
value those things on the other hand men
simply for the most part don't care
about a woman's career ambitions
they don't want a lazy bump on a log
either but they value and are attracted
to a different sort of energy and
ambition in women
i've said before that my wife is
extremely talented has many skills more
skills than i have
and is quite ambitious but she doesn't
have a professional career she parents
ambitiously
she mothers ambitiously she um pours her
energy into her family she has many
creative talents and always finds
different outlets for them sometimes
she'll find outlets that earn money
sometimes not
but the money doesn't really matter to
me
i didn't marry her in hopes that she
would provide an income for me
no man gets married for that reason
even men who are married to working
women as plenty are still didn't choose
those women because of their income
potential
women hopefully aren't choosing men
solely on income but the man's ability
to provide for his family will be a
major factor in her decision
for men it's just not
men are not thinking about that
they're not thinking when it when
they're when they're with a woman and
think about marriage not that well she
would do great at
providing an income for the family
if they think that she can they may see
that as a bonus but that's they're not
making decisions based on that
and it also doesn't mean by the way that
low-income men low-income single men are
out of luck a woman is also assessing
potential
so even if you aren't making much money
now
she might still consider you an
excellent match if she sees that you
work hard and have aspirations and the
drive to achieve them women are good at
this by the way they have a natural
intuition about these sorts of things
a good wife will often have a clear idea
of her husband's career potential than
he does
she can't anticipate his future success
even if his predictions about his own
future are far more modest than hers
what this all means
boiled down is that men and women are
different and they want different things
our cultural institutions have spent
years and decades trying to collapse
these two categories into one ambiguous
indistinguishable mess
and yet in spite of that
still these fundamental differences
remain
girls are told from a young age i mean
it's hammered into their heads
that they shouldn't look to men to be
providers
and boys are told that they shouldn't
see themselves in that role
and yet
both groups gravitate this way anyway
attempts are made to evade these
differences get around them
and most of these attempts end in
disaster
note how a woman's likelihood of divorce
increases as her income increases
while the trend is exactly the opposite
for men
and that's because
women are attracted to men who provide
so if he pours himself into that role as
provider
the woman's attraction will grow
stronger and deeper
of course some men can go too far they
prioritize their careers over their
families
and many divorces have happened as a
result of that but as long as he's
putting his family first and valuing his
job
in large part because he values his
family and takes his provider role
seriously then it should only strengthen
his marriage
yet a woman who invests herself more and
more into the into her career is not
going to find that it has the same
positive effect on her marriage
necessarily because her husband doesn't
fundamentally see her as a provider
he may support her career
but he doesn't find her career ambition
attractive in the same way that a woman
does for a man
and
there are a lot of men who listen who
are listening to this right now and feel
like they have to disagree with me and
say no that's not true
my my woman is my wife is a
very ambitious in her career and a great
businesswoman
and i just find it so sexy and
attractive
no you don't not really i mean you're
saying that because you think you have
to but you don't really
again thousands and thousands of years
of
of human behavior tell us the truth here
and also if the woman becomes more
successful in her career than than the
man is in his it can lead to resentment
because the man will begin to feel that
he has no essential role that he's no
longer necessary this is not me
prescribing how things should be i'm
just describing how they are and always
have been
we've been conditioned to recoil from
the notion of gender roles the term
almost always is used in a pejorative
way now
but at their root
gender roles were never rules it wasn't
society saying what men and women
should do or most must do gender roles
were our way of categorizing what men
and women already naturally tend to do
and it's good to have a grasp on that
because without it couples go into
marriage not sure what to do or what
their role should be
invariably they end up stepping on each
other's toes competing with rather than
complimenting each other
this is why it's good to have a healthy
understanding of and respect for
traditional gender roles quote unquote
even if you're going to do something
different in your own family
it's good to know what the original
recipe is before you come up with your
variation of it
what happens these days is that both the
man and the woman stand in the kitchen
dumping all kinds of competing
ingredients into the bowl mixing it
together and the end result is confused
and weird and rarely successful
and that's the result of trying to deny
what we all inherently know to be true
so who are we canceling today we're not
canceling gender roles because those
can't be cancelled not completely
instead i guess this is another reverse
cancellation we're canceling the people
who have tried to cancel the gender
roles
because that's just never actually going
to work
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producer is mathis glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo vadosky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin